now before we get on to policy I want to
talk to you about a tweet exchange that
you had with a certain young
conservative just explain to us what
happened oh well we should do this
quickly because it's not a huge issue
but there's an important Point behind it
young conservative coming here for the
conference described in his Twitter
Birmingham was quote unquote a dump now
you might say turn the other cheek but
there is a really important point about
how perceptions of cities are we have
spent decades trying to rebuild the
perception of this place think of the
success of the Commonwealth Games this
summer I think of the International
Investment that comes in on the back of
that so my job is always to defend the
brand the reputation of this city and
that's why I took him to task on Twitter
it's also damaging for the conservative
party brand isn't it well I want
everyone who comes here for conference
this week is why we so enjoy hosting it
and frankly we'd enjoy hosting it was
the labor party as well to go away
thinking this place is really making
progress back them they'll make further
progress so I can't have anyone in the
conservative party off message now I'm
really interested to have you on the
program this morning because genuinely I
don't know where your head is at right
the last thing I can see that you
tweeted um publicly about politics other
than Birmingham related or West Midlands
related thing it was on the 5th of
September when Liz truss won the
leadership contest you said the first
thing for Liz truss is in tomorrow's
interest got to be getting a grip on the
cost of living pressures then doubling
down on leveling up now you could argue
of course that the energy support
package was getting a grip on those cost
of living pressures I'm sure you would
welcome that how is doubling down on
leveling up going yeah so let's just
acknowledge the first point that you've
been fair about two weeks ago everyone
was saying is the government going to
act on the cost of living pressure and
more precisely the energy cost and they
did decide simply and of course we know
that as of yesterday when prices would
have gone up the new price regime comes
in and for a person with an average
semi-detached house in this city it's a
saving of about 1100 pounds against what
it would be so there was decisive action
on that and we should all acknowledge
that in terms of leveling up that's
going to take a little longer part of
course of this conference is to show
that if you invest in a region like this
we will deliver we will pay back but the
first real piece of evidence of leveling
up is of course the announcement in the
million budget of the investment zones
and I fervently welcome that we are
sitting actually just next to probably
the most successful Enterprise Zone
anywhere in Britain that has seen the
Redevelopment of the city center here
investment zones which have been many
more places is a sort of Enterprise Zone
on steroids the policy definitely works
we've proved that we want to be as quick
as can to get that off the ground from
the interview with Jake Barry it's very
clear that the government is not going
to go back on scrapping the 45p rate of
additional tax if you're a millionaire
that would be worth 55 000 pounds to you
in a tax cut and they've also not
confirmed that benefits will be operated
in line with inflation is that leveling
up
so that's a that is a total decision
across the whole country of course
leveling up is much more focused and
that's why I've given you the answer I
have but to be really clear for us to
level up generally you've got to lift
lift the qualifications and the
aspirations of the people who are
probably the just about managing as many
many of those in this city and for them
the re the energy price action was
absolutely critical and also of course
for them the National Insurance
reduction applied to everybody was
critical but the most important thing is
where is the jobs of the future going to
come from and that's why I was also very
keen to see some of the things in the
statement which were about in business
investment because they will produce the
new sectors The Net Zero sector of the
future the jobs for people in this city
but if you are a just about managing
family in Birmingham as you say and you
look at the budget and you think oh my
goodness me um I welcome the support and
energy with Bill as well how am I going
to afford my food shop I'm really
worried about my public services and you
hear the government say they want to
make spending cards but they're also
going to give a fifty five thousand
pound tax cut to the very wealthiest
they have not yet said they are
definitely going to make any spending
cuts they're saying they're reviewing
public spending every government says
that in time because they have to
balance the books nothing has come
through actually if you look at public
spending we're actually committed at the
moment to the huge increases in the
public spending that Boris Johnson's
government brought about and probably
the most important thing if you ask
people in this city would be the
investment in the Health Service which
as I understand it is absolutely uh
stood by
um our spending cuts the right thing to
do you should always review government
spending I mean I ran a huge business
for many years you can't just go
you can't go on year after year without
reviewing your core that is good
business it's good leadership of the
public finances would I advocate because
in the Health Services of course not the
country is crying out for investment in
the Health Service and that's why
boris's government did it and I believe
this government will support it but that
doesn't mean Sophie we shouldn't have an
intelligent conversation about value for
money in public spending and that's
what's been proposed what would you like
to have seen a full obr forecaster at
the same time in the budget is not
slated until the 23rd of no I'd like to
see it come forward very as soon as
possible frankly because there's an
issue of confidence here I mean what
what actually has happened last week is
the huge majority of things that were
done in the final in the financial
statement the market had already
expected them and actually was accepting
of them and the biggest issue of course
was 150 billion pounds for energy in the
market got that but then there were
probably some surprises and so what
we've got to do is actually reassure the
market and one of the best ways of doing
that is with the predictions from the
obr what surprises do you mean well it's
clear the two the I mean the chancellor
used the word didn't he rabbits out of
the Hat I mean you couldn't get more
evidence that that's where he was
thinking and I think the two things that
were probably the surprise was the top
rate of tax and that's what's generated
all the observation but my key point is
the huge financial investments were not
the surprises and the market had
accepted them before it happened do you
support the uh if it was me I wouldn't
have done that to be really clear I
wouldn't have done that but I understand
that the government is attempting to I
agree with the whole principle of we've
got to get growth going we and it's why
I voted for this trust and I stand by
that because we were in a position that
really over the last seven years we'd
seen the underlying rate of growth of
this country's economy softening you
cannot pay for all the Public Services
everyone expects with that situation so
a different way of thinking was required
and the huge majority of investments in
the financial statement was about that
different way of thinking and why
wouldn't you done the 45p uh rate of tax
I know is that what you're saying about
growth and The Wider plan but why
specifically that because because I
think that's the lesson of History if
you look at what's happened uh certainly
in Thatcher's time and what Reagan did
you have to carry the huge majority of
people with you in the early stages of
this and as we're now seeing that's
proving a difficult thing to do but
principle of what the prime minister is
doing is saying we're going to have a
different approach to growth is what I
fully stand by
um you say that you need to bring people
with you and the importance of that and
certainly if you look at the polls and
look at what Jake Barry says you know
we're a long way out you know a poll as
a pole but there is a clear Trend here
and it is quite jaw-dropping leads for
labor the kind of police they haven't
seen since the late 1990s
so so I'm sure they're celebrating that
but I'm sure the mood here will be one
of utter Defiance we've seen incredibly
difficult positions for this party
before remember May of 2019 Theresa May
European elections I think we got nine
percent of the vote so we are not unused
to having to come back from really
difficult positions but the way you do
it is you lay out your stall and you
demonstrate you are going to deliver and
that's why coming back to your second
question I would always say the thing
this party's got to do is show that it's
delivering for people in this region and
my job is to make sure they leave
Birmingham even more committed to doing
that and a lot of MPS though a lot of
conservative MPS are going to be looking
at those polls and they're going to be
very very worried and the conclusion
that they will draw is that the
conservatives are going to lose the next
election and they'd be right when they
far too soon to draw any conclusion like
that we've seen polls move around
they've moved so quickly just in a few
days so so we've seen that fragility in
polls so all that we can do is to double
down on the task ahead of us and
actually demonstrate that the plan is
going to deliver and so that we can pay
for those Public Services get the better
jobs for people in this region okay just
a final thought Jake Barry committing to
climate change at targets but there is
some speculation about the government's
position on it particularly with the
story at the King Charles was advised
not to attend the next cop Summit you've
obviously been someone who has
championed green issues yes for
environmental reasons also the growth
reasons what would your message be to be
on this I do not turn do not compromise
and actually there is no conflict
between the cost of living crisis and
the climate crisis there actually can be
addressed in the same way it's a
critical thing that this party actually
has developed really good position on
and we must not compromise and by the
way go and see our electric bus outside
this outside the conference center and
you will see the investment into Net
Zero in this region okay I'll go and
check it out thank you very much Andy
Street there